[Música]
muchos creen que la muerte es lo único
que tenemos que sentarnos a esperar
cuando envejecemos lo contrario piensa
en las personas que ya han envejecido
digo esto porque durante toda mi
experiencia como economista en este
mundo de la Protección Social he visto
miles y miles de rostros de personas
mayores que buscan un propósito una
razón para despertarse todos los días
y América Latina y el Caribe la dinámica
demográfica de están cambiando
rápidamente y están dejando al
descubierto la importancia y la
relevancia que tiene lo que
internacionalmente se conoce como la
Silver economía
o defino como toda toda la actividad
económica que se genera alrededor de la
producción de bienes y servicios para el
bienestar de las personas mayores
porque la Silver conomia es tan
importante y porque va a cobrar
muchísima más mayor relevancia en
nuestra región la dinámica demográfica
no está indicando una cosa según
Naciones Unidas
somos 650 millones de habitantes en toda
la región de los cuales 58000000 son
personas mayores de 65 años
esto no sería novedoso ninguna noticia
solo por pensar que a final del siglo
para el 2100 tenemos 670 millones de
latinoamericanos de los cuales 200 213
serán personas mayores mayores de 65
años imágenes o salir a la calle
ver a 100 personas hoy en día y 9 de
ellas son adultos mayores o personas
mayores abrir y cerrar los ojos salir a
la calle nuevamente
y descubrir que son más de 30 las
personas que están esas condiciones
todas cambiar nuestro panorama
demografico obviamente
social y especialmente el económico el
económico alrededor de esta silver
economía
y de quién estamos hablando al servicio
de quién está la Silver economy a Maya
que de personas mayores personas que
superan cierta edad que están son
carnosas tal vez de arrugas son personas
que buscan con ansiedad todos los días
encontrar un propósito ya lo mencionaba
tener porque la razón para despertarse
todos los días voy al otro día una
noticia de la persona de mayor edad
trabajando en la cadena de comida rápida
más famosas EEUU tal vez del mundo
decía el que no tiene ningún plan de
retirarse con 92 años
o también veía el caso de una uruguaya
que a los 93 años termino los estudios
de primaria y se está preparando para
continuar también la secundaria
son personas que huyen rápidamente a la
soledad no quieren estar solas
buscan pareja
veías la celebración de una boda de un
hombre 82 años con una mujer de 38
muchos jóvenes preguntan ya asada para
que casarse solo ellos saben para qué
mira también la historia una mujer en
Italia
93 años también que llamo a la policía
reportar un falso rojo porque quería que
la policía le acompañara en ese día que
se sentía muy sola
pero son personas también que odian les
frustra detectan que sean discriminadas
positiva o negativamente un par de días
la reina Isabel segunda en el Reino
Unido
rechazaba el premio como la anciana del
año ya decías no eso no es para mí yo no
soy ninguna vieja no quiero tu premio
son personas que además y en nivel
económico pues tienen ingresos de algo
viven ingresos que no dependen del ciclo
económico
una gran proporción de ellas por ejemplo
tienen pensión
en América Latina hay unos ejemplos de
lo relevante
y los gruesos que son el tema de las
pensiones en países como Brasil o
Argentina el 11% del Producto Interno
Bruto todos los años se va al pago de
pensiones
son recursos que podríamos nosotros
construir una carretera de cuatro
carriles alrededor del planeta Tierra
2500 veces la cantidad de recursos que
están ahí a disposición de ponerlo al
servicio de un modelo de desarrollo
económico para todos
además de eso es pensemos en cómo
podemos aprovecharlo cómo podemos
hacerlo
lo único que tenemos que hacer es lograr
el encuentro de dos cosas primero la
búsqueda hasta hoy muy desatendida del
bienestar de las personas mayores y
también la búsqueda de ellos de su
felicidad y encontrarás hacerlas que se
casen que hay un matrimonio real con un
modelo de desarrollo alrededor de la
Silver economía que puedan maximizar el
bienestar de todos nosotros
hablemos algunos sectores económicos
como el caso de la vivienda por ejemplo
hay miles miles de proyectos en toda la
región que yo mismo también he
descubierto que están ahí
silenciosamente destinado a personas
mayores mucho más allá de ancianatos
hogares de paso son proyectos
de altos ingresos de personas que ya
están edad retiro y que se encuentran
ahí para vivir juntas también hablemos
del sector de entretenimiento
pez conoce en un bar un restaurante
destinado a las personas mayores de sus
vecindarios cierto que no o no es muy
frecuente
ya ves ya personas que se dedican a
viajar conocer una persona señora de 75
años que ha conocido 66 países y ella
decía que la pandemia no gustaba de
teniendo ganas de conquistar el mundo
también son personas que demandan es muy
avanzada
Servicio de Salud especializada
algunas todavía tratamientos estéticos
antiedad pero sobre todo en normas
oportunidades ahí en el cuidado de las
personas mayores
cuidado que oiga front a un enorme
déficit de personas que deberían estar
trabajando en ese sector personas tal
vez en situación de pobreza o jóvenes
desempleados pueden encontrar en estas
actividades
un mejor futuro
de tal manera que la Silver economía
no ofrece únicamente una oportunidad
sino un camino para poder canalizar
todas las energías y las motivaciones
que todavía tiene la población adulta
para que todos tengamos un mayor
bienestar para que las empresas puedan
mejorar su productividad sus ventas para
que las personas puedan encontrar más y
mejores empleos pero sobre todo y
finalmente para que las personas mayores
finalmente puedan contar con un mayor
nivel de bienestar y felicidad
muchísimas gracias
[Música]